je vais chanter moi même là où ça bouge
c'est l'agenda pour vous annoncer
charlie saussaie à blainville sur mer
pour un concert en hommage à leny
escudero son ami ce sera dimanche à 16
heures à la salle des fêtes de
blainville sur mer
tout à fait la suite de l'agenda avec
sabine d'ayem c'est disco new wave et
qui offre tout ça mélangé les naïve new
beaters présentent leur nouvel album à
la folie à la luciole ce soir à 21h
vous la présenter cette semaine laurent
picot envisage bashung ce soir à 20h30 à
l'espace tandem tout le week end la
garde républicaine serait en pôle
hippique de saint lô ce sont de bons
cavaliers mais aussi de bons musiciens
c'est à 21h ce soir et demain
art floral et broderies et agneaux avec
notamment des démonstrations publiques
faites par des maîtres internationaux
d'art floral
le
keren ann sera 20h30 au théâtre de
coutances ce soir pour présenter son
nouvel album intitulé you gonna get love
je respire finalement qu'à quelques
libertés
le festival au chapiteau de lisieux
c'est tout le week end
douze concerts avec notamment mado les
frères tinner et les ratures c'est
gratuit pour toute la famille ce soir à
23 heures et jusqu'au bout de la nuit le
cargö de caen propose une super soirée
musicale
en attendant en orbite un braque extra
doux blixen techno anthony parasols ryan
elliott et bien d'autres fatigables
éternelle comme une usine et son pardon
banon mais pas vous les gars sont les
îlots le groupe h ils seront à l'espace
buisson de tourlaville mardi prochain à
20h45
à
j'ai eu peur ce que j'ai l'impression
que c'est vrai que c'est moi aussi bah
oui